all righty this year's game awards
nominees have been
revealed
uh i'm excited to look through it it was
a really weird year for game of the year
actually the podcast last week play
which listen last week we kind of spoke
about this where there have been loads
of games that have come out this year
but a lot of them are very specialized
being that a lot of what came out this
year really only appeals to a smaller
group of people i mean ratchet only
certain people are going to play a 3d
platformer like that return obviously
off putting too large swaps of people
even though i think that game absolutely
rules um death loop people are like
really hit or miss on it so it was kind
of hard to guess
what
would be the the the
main picks but um let's let's have a
look do i just scroll or do i stop
voting
game of the year here we go
i should move my camera
let me put myself up here
all right game of the year
we have death loop
confirmed
i
i should look at the others oh yeah it
takes two came up in all the
conversations as well it takes two
rules um
i think that that game
is really really good in a really
interesting way um
it's not also not necessarily something
that's gonna appeal to everyone i think
my it takes two video which i made with
ethan crank gameplays put up on this
channel has like the least views of
anything that i uploaded in the last 12
months
but the game itself uh is so creative
and especially now that i work in game
development having the perspective of
like
knowing how difficult it is to make that
many mechanics they made so many mini
games
um
and it it has them uh in spades like it
would have been really hard to make it's
so creative it's really fun
um an awesome experience but i think
probably off-putting to some people
based on the way that it looks and also
on the requirement for for co-op
i thought they did a great job if one if
he has it the other one gets to play
free metroid dread not surprised that
that's there either um metro dread is is
really great but feels like it kind of
disappeared from conversations after
people yelled about it being too hard
ah psychonauts second odds too
um i love that game my only issue with
psychonauts 2 was
slightly more cut scenes that i would
have liked
ration clank and resident evil village i
wasn't sure if that would get nominated
i think in other years it probably
wouldn't get nominated um i think it's
really good i enjoyed it i loved the um
the castle especially it feels like
classic resident evil it's a good time
um
i don't know i don't i can't really tell
you why i wouldn't have expected it yeah
i played through the whole thing here um
of these i think death loop is my pick
i really really enjoyed it um
they're all good games
literally all of these games are really
good um my my personal game of the year
is a game called inscription which i
never would have expected to make this
and for the record for anyone who
doesn't know how this stuff works i've
been on the game awards jury a number of
times um i've done bafta jerry's anita
kid juries and a number of other um game
award juries
the game awards specifically is a lot of
people there's no like requirement to
even play every game which others do
have um indicate and bafta for example
you do have to play all the games that
are
um
like considered to be nominated and then
the nominees are selected and then from
there the winners are selected the way
that the game awards does it is to get
such a broad amount of people to to vote
it is kind of a popularity contest um
that's just one of the limitations and
running a game awards show is really
hard to do so
there are different ways to do it but i
get the way that they do it um
essentially just anybody who's on the
jury which i don't know like a hundred
outlets i'm guessing i'm not really sure
just gets to submit whatever games they
want there's no requirement to play
every game that came out in the year um
that means you're gonna get more votes
and of course they have a lot of fan
voted stuff too um i think that weighs
in every decision
but it does mean that it's going to be
the stuff that people are most likely to
have played in any given year so glad to
see metro dread there for sure because i
feel like
it probably has sold well
i'm just seeing it spoken about
less than i would have thought
considering how excited everybody seemed
to be for it
um but yeah inscription was never going
to make it because it's a little indie
baby
um
and i loved death's door and i'm
actually i wish that store was here that
would have been nice but yeah it's just
like so many people vote and it's just
whatever the most voted for games get
picked essentially that's how it works
oh next category
best game direction
the exact same games plus return hmm
what would i pick for game direction i
think the game direction i would go one
of these two
um
game direction in my head at least is
generally whichever game
clearly had a vision and very clearly
executed upon it actually returnable as
well
no they're all good that's tough they're
all good because like psychonauts 2 is a
fantastic direction
tim shafer everybody that's they are all
very very good i feel like
i would go
it takes two for this one
for game of the year i would go
definitely
i don't want to sign in so i'm not gonna
vote um
it takes two would be direction because
it's hard to pull up what they pulled
off
best narrative
um
i've not played life is strange but it
seems like a immediate darling i did
play marvel's guardians of the galaxy
but not as much as i should have what
would i go with for best narrative
hmm i feel like life is strange is the
most likely to win being that it's a
very narrative based game
i reckon i go with psychonauts honestly
that's tough though that's a tough one
best art direction ah glad to see artful
escape there beautiful game kana
obviously beautiful for me i think it
would be kana because the art direction
of that game is so obvious and so like
clear and coherent and specific um
myself again just trying to figure out
where to put myself there we go that
seems better um
well like you know it's clear that the
studio came from an animation background
and that that influenced the entire
design and it's really really really
cohesive it's that's a it's a gorgeous
game yeah i'm stoked for them for amber
lab it's their first game i believe so
that's extra cool but
full escape
is one of the only games that i like
finished fully on stream this year as
well
and um
it's really cool it's very unique and
and stunning so it's got to be between
these two for me i actually didn't love
the art direction of death loop i i
appreciate what they did second one's
two is cool and exciting 100 ratchet is
gorgeous like so impressive but
these two stand out to me the most i
think
best score and music hey the only one of
these that i'm still listening to is
cyberpunk 2077 i listen to the
soundtrack
frequently um songs on my recurring
playlist
um i actually also probably would have
put them in art
i do think the art there is very good
artful escape it's a music game
um
near replicant though that would be
a big one for me i've always loved the
music of nia
uh akabe is incredible
yeah i'd go with nia even though
cyberpunk is the one that i'm listening
to the most that the the music in their
replicant is like
just makes you feel something you know
what i mean
best audio design
forza horizon 5 is a good call there
actually surprise forza didn't get the
game of the year now i'm considering i
think it's currently
the highest rated game of the year but
it's an issue with
when the games come out like people
submit their votes at different times
and i also feel like there's just like a
stigma against putting a racing game or
a sports game
that far on the top that's just a thing
people just don't consider them that way
but it's also
considering the dates demon souls would
also be included in theory like that
demon souls remake is fantastic i would
have game of the year nominated that um
i probably also would have put that in
sound design
of these i'm gonna go with resident evil
or eternal though eternal i reckon it's
fraternal
best performance
ah maggie she was so good
juliana is fantastic
called obviously very good i mean
i mean
that feels like cheating
i played like a stranger can't comment
on that
these are all these are all fantastic
i'm actually gonna say juliana would get
my vote um i loved maggie as lady d i
interviewed her she was awesome and so
cool to talk to and
and clearly so talented not that they're
all not talented but um i think juliana
brings this like edge that is difficult
for a character it's often coming
through your playstation controller i i
would go with her for that one
games for impact okay
i generally don't play enough of these
before your eyes i just learned about
and have not played i haven't played any
of these games
none of them
i'm sorry i should
best ongoing hmm
if that doesn't go to final fantasy
i would be very surprised fortnite is
always nominated
gentian
call of duty is also very popular i
would go final fantasy
for sure best indie this is where we got
to see my boys there we go there we go
my two favorite games of the year
um
inscription it's inscription death store
is fantastic as well and also
both the volvo oh loop heroes devolver
as well and then obviously annapurna for
12 minutes which
unfortunately missed the mark for a lot
of us i think but yeah
description play it it's very good
best mobile game that's not going to be
a category for me i don't touch them
unfortunately
best community support
it's interesting i would have actually
put um among us in here you know
i think they've been doing a really good
job nice to see no man's sky get get
recognized with this stuff um
i have virtually no opinion on this
category at all
presented by chevrolet innovation and
accessibility
i'm gonna go forza but i've not played
the veil
forza would take it for me i think
best ar vr huh whoa i didn't even know
hitman 3 was playable in vr
damn
my pick is going to go to resident evil
4 though it's so good i i'm so happy
it's so fun like i'm just chuffed
best action game
i would go with return all we've got
death loop far cry 6 because death loop
isn't really like my kind of
action game if that makes sense um
i'd go with fraternal for that but back
for blood was fun far cry 6 was fun like
they're all fun i've not played chivalry
2 but all fun games next is best action
adventure hmm
interesting i guess metroid dread
technically is an action adventure
i guess resident evil technically is as
well both of those feel strange um
what would i go for for action adventure
i'm gonna say psychonauts too for that
one
but i do feel like guardians of the
galaxy like
came in harder than expected um
obviously we're just seeing similar
games repeatedly though here though
which is like just the big ones
it happens best rpg
cyberpunk monster hunter scarlet nexus
shin megami tensei and tales of arise i
have only played these two
uh clearly
lagging on rpgs would near not count
would near replicant not count as an rpg
or is that an action adventure
if so
devastating to see it not be included um
for me it's gonna be cyberpunk
best fighting
i haven't touched any of them
can't really play fighting games anymore
my wrists can't take fighting games that
is uh
how i kind of got into caring about
video game accessibility so much is that
i have accessibility needs for certain
games and i have a lot of trouble with
fighting games anything that requires
rapid button presses i kind of can't do
so it's a it's a genre that i used to
really love that i can't really touch
anymore it's a shame
best family
i did enjoy new pokemon snap
i would give it to it takes two
the warrior was pretty lit too i'd give
it to takes you for that one it is
literally about families
best sim slash strategy
oh inscription for sure then
best game focused on real-time or
turn-based simulation or strategy
gameplay irrespective of platform
i didn't play age of empires i should i
loved it as a kid i've never even heard
of evil geniuses evil genius
evil geniuses is the esports team
it's inscription [ __ ] brilliant game
sports racing i would give to
forza similar nominations pretty much
every year though
best multiplayer
oh it's strange
valheim was so good i haven't played new
world
monster hunter is always good
it takes two really ah i had a lot of
fun with a lot of these games this year
honestly but i'm actually gonna say
valheim for me personally um in part
because it was really unexpected like i
didn't see it coming and it did and i'm
happy about it um but this is a good
aside from having not played new world
this is a very
good list of games that like
were awesome to play through this year
like no doubt
content creator of the year i was here
last year
dream firstly goals
i buy and graph
i don't know any of these people
i'm sure they're great
um it's
important and positive impact is the
thing to note so like i think i was
nominated last year because of charity
work and the accessibility awards and
that stuff so
but i don't know who these people are
i'm sure they're great
best debut indie
forgotten city
i still haven't played fable sable and i
should
i'm gonna go with forgotten city because
i think the story of it is especially
cool like how that game came about it's
previously a mod and then turned into a
game that everybody loves is like such a
cool
debut
um
kana is obviously awesome
artful escape is like a very cool game
but
less impressive in terms of gameplay i
think they're always good though but i
would give it to forgotten city for that
one seems like that should have been
included in narrative actually shame
that it wasn't
again less popular i suppose
most anticipated game
hit us
all incredible games what a year
but naturally hi i'm lana i work at sony
santa monica studio sie
and uh
pretty excited about god of war ragnarok
coming out personally
that's all i'm saying but i'm really
excited about all these games i mean how
can you not you know
yeah the hot across the board all good
but
and i just wanted to say like
video games are real hard to make
congratulations to all of these studios
thank you for everything that you do
appreciate you
esports game
probably valorent right now
but this has got to look pretty similar
across years as well i would think right
esports athlete i'm not going to know
any of these people either
what what do you got here what are all
these
badges or something
based on picture we got to give it to
tyson
but um that's not really how these
things work esports team
i'm glad to see them included but it's
not something i know anything about
unfortunately
i will still show you on screen
but i don't know anything about you i'm
sorry
this is category 30
esports event
i always love the international
i used to cover it in the early stages
of my career back when i did know things
about esports i don't really anymore
um
yeah a kind of unexciting list this year
ultimately um because a lot of games got
pushed this year which
you know changes the landscape of
releases
obviously
um death loop would be the one out of
these that i would pick for game of the
year or rather the one that i think will
win
but it takes two make a great case for
the metroid dread
all of them all of them i think these
these bottom three are less likely
to win uh versus one of these three but
i'm gonna guess it's death loop
um even though again mine is inscription
or death store personally death loop is
for sure up there as well um but yeah
i'm really excited to actually go to the
event in person this year uh obviously
last year i was nominated and i did an
ad so i was part of it technically but
it was the whole thing was virtual so
this year you're really nice to to go in
person and celebrate video games and i
always whenever i talk about the stuff
when i remind people
it's just people's opinions that's it
just people's opinions if you disagree
it ultimately doesn't matter it doesn't
mean it's rigged it is just people's
opinions i promise you it's not right
there's way too many people to vote it'd
be so hard to coordinate or get leaked
um it's it's a lot of people go into
voting for these games but it like
it just doesn't matter that much you
know that's my my big takeaway every
year is like it's a cool fun thing that
jeff
and his team clearly put a lot of work
into and making an award show is hot let
me tell you as someone who's doing it
themselves it's tough um i respect the
hell out of of the the effort and the
spectacle
you know catered to celebrating the
games industry but
i think you're just cheating yourself if
you take it too seriously ultimately so
it is what it is but yeah it's on
december 9 i think
december 9th can't wait it'll be a good
time
um let me know what you guys think what
do you think should be game of the year
is there anything that i missed that i
should have played that i didn't check
out i'd love to know
and i will see you guys next time bye